[Music]
chat Bots like chat GPT are all over the
Internet helping with customer service
or writing code essays and emails and
talking to them can feel remarkably like
talking to something sentient but don't
be fooled as chat GPT and its cousins
spread it's becoming ever more important
for us to know exactly what we're
talking to in the next 3 minutes I'm
going to explain what chat GPT is and
perhaps more importantly what it isn't
first what is chat
GPT AI chatbots are conversational
agents based on what's called a large
language model or llm llms are neural
networks that are trained on trillions
of tokens symbols and words taken from
online documents they learn the
structure of this data and its patterns
and then given an input or prompt they
generate plausible language that fits
the patterns of their training material
they they do this word by word at each
point analyzing the information so far
and generating the next statistically
plausible token it's a bit like an
autocomplete with some Randomness added
so it doesn't always give the same reply
this amount of Randomness called
temperature can be set low so the llm
picks only from the most likely options
or high so the llm chooses from a wider
range of possible next words chat GPT is
a dialogue agent built on top of this
model it has some extrafine tuning and
hidden prompts to restrict and steer how
it responds that gives it the character
of a helpful assistant the latest
versions of chat GPT are also hooked up
to different systems so they can
interpret and produce images as well as
language prompts so what is chat GPT not
well it's not an independent agent it
has no intentions or self-serving goals
its function is solely to generate
dialogue one word at a time it can't
give a confidence level in its answer or
fact check and has no concept of of
whether what it's saying is true or
false this is that a lot of people to
say chat GPT is not intelligent but what
does that
mean some computer scientists Define
intelligence simply as being able to do
tasks as capably as a human in that
sense chat GPT is intelligent when it
comes to some tasks but that
intelligence is extremely limited for
example chat GPT fails simple logic
puzzles that humans find easy another
question is whether chat Bots can re
reason or understand the world llms
build up vast internal models of how our
language works so some researchers argue
that they effectively do understand the
meanings of words and symbols others
dispute that partly because the
comparison with human understanding is
so limited llms don't experience the
objects and Concepts that our language
describes and their objective is only to
generate plausible next pieces of data
but what about in the future could AIS
like Chachi PT one day be the root of
more general intelligence able to match
humans at a wide range of tasks and
solve unfamiliar problems that's what
many computer scientists are aiming for
some think that they just require more
data more processing power and more bits
of AI software hooked together others
say that the underlying mechanism of
generating responses word by word will
simply never be enough it might take new
and different types of breakthroughs for
AI to achieve a more humanlike
intelligence
if that ever happens for now though it's
important that we all understand how
chat GPT is coming up with its human
sounding responses and that we avoid
being fooled as to its true
nature